el chavismo toma el control en la
asamblea nacional con un 91 por ciento
el partido oficialista confirmó su
mayoría aplastante tras los comicios del
6 de diciembre el pueblo venezolano el
día de hoy convertido en juntas
regionales electorales ejerciendo su
servicio electoral obligatorio proclama
y entrega las credenciales a su
representante de la asamblea nacional
electo para el periodo 2021 2026 en las
24 entidades del país que no estuvo
presente fue el líder del sector
opositor juan guaidó ni él ni su partido
fueron autorizados para presentarse a
unas elecciones que titulan de
fraudulentas al mismo tiempo pusieron en
marcha una consulta popular nacional que
concluirá hoy
derrota que se llevó una dictadura
a devolver
[Música]
esta consulta se lleva celebrando de
manera virtual desde el 7 de diciembre
por medio del portal consulta por
venezuela.com siente el celo su pasión
del presidente por parte nicolás maduro
como cada las elecciones presidenciales
el rechazo del evento del 6 de diciembre
si ordenadamente adelantar la gestión
necesariamente internacional si estos
dos comicios dejando un país y
representación para la oposición
asamblearia venezolana al menos hasta
2026 que ellos saben que no pueden ellos
no pueden porque no es que el tiempo de
ellos se les acabó ellos no entienden de
aquí aquí no manda maduro de que aquí no
mandan los ministros de aquí no mandan
la diputada que manda es un pueblo un
pueblo un pueblo arrecho que él reclama
su derecho esto lo que está pasando aquí
en venezuela los contrarios al
oficialismo de maduro se quedan así sin
demasiadas vías legales para actuar